hi oh yes sir for a second group
presentation the day up this is the
group that might want an island and so
have lost blindness actually kinda when
were talking about on the filibusters
reason
I have Justin
she
and cap and a fucking pigeon said about
know enough for durable surgeries a lot
of trestles so just a brief roadmap
we're going to talk about risk we're
going to sort of motivate their results
will be beginning which are about what's
called a boy or girl awesome and how
space conjecture we're going to talk
about these specific pieces in which we
study this conjecture which is gain
surgery optimistic towards knots we're
gonna talk a little bit about previous
results for these specific cases and
then we're going to talk about our
results and a little bit of our
methodology and then maybe some things
that are yet to be proved so let's start
with left or durability I say that a
non-trivial group is left were durable
if there exists a strict total order on
the group essentially which respects
left multiplication within the group so
G has less than H then after you must be
less than a sage cranny ethnic group an
example of a left for a little group is
seeing it under addition
just with nest and recorder we all know
if you have an inequality you add the
same thing to both sides
surely you must get inequality that's
still true and you're not example is
actually see ma a.m. under addition in
fact you can prove that any group which
has a finite element pastina left or
it'll be this
some gear cheap an element are here I
don't know where now she she must be
either greater than or less than
identity right without loss of
generality assume it's creative editing
so she is greater than one
well we know that it's if we assuming I
say G is greater than fun well now we
can multiply on both sides by G so you
get G super creative gene but emoji is
available so G squared is greater than
one we can sort of see if you keeps
multiplying Reggie you'll have to get up
to G to the N is greater than 1 but this
is one have the greater than one so in
fact this period demonstrates that C Mon
Eman and any other group in plant order
elements is not that durable
now we're gonna talk about the here at
flora chronology if you're familiar with
dr. great apology might suspect that
this apology would associate a vector
space or the sequence of created groups
to some kind of topological space in
this case we're interested in three net
holes as they're collectible spaces and
the hangar floor technology will
associate vector space with coefficients
and f2 or ZMOT - so we say that a closed
connected or absolutely not
is Intel space in capacitor the simplest
possible figure terminology now we have
enough things to find to talk about this
conjecture which is the mean domain the
conjecture that we've been studied while
summer the studio where gardener Watson
says that irreducible rational and
logical priests care isn't else basic
and only if it's fundamental group is
not that durable so rational monologic
face barriers just particular kind of
clothes effective graphical pre-medical
irreducible just means you can't sort of
break it up as the sum of other animals
here we're talking about to connect
stuff yeah so these these make other
kinds of animals projection to the else
pieces it's not only after fundamental
group is not that variable yeah this is
really really noteworthy because the hey
Arthur mammalogy and fun amount group my
purity very different structures so the
idea that property of want monkey of
equivalent to offer you another the
other is really not to be like yet and
so the summer we were interested in
trying to verify this conjecture for
certain three kind of bolts which
it's got side of the goal of our
research is to help verify this
conjecture mom
there has conjecture so in order to do
that we need to find some of these
particular L spaces so that we can look
at their fundamental grooves that I'm
struck their left or durability
conjecture so in order to get some of
these to be manifolds let's start
looking at knots right so I'm not as
exactly what you think it is it's
basically the embedding of the circle
into our s3 and here's another example
of a knot and a particularly interesting
one is the torus knot so what you do the
case in the torus knot is you take a
torus right and you basically inscribe
your embedding an s-1 along the torrance
right so I'm protecting what you can do
is you can take a pair P Q right and
that's your wrap key times around this
way you wrap to Q times around the
meridian right we call this the TP q
before side so this is one picture of it
another's like this you can sort of also
figure that as taking three strands
giving them five whole twists and then
closing it all so so I think more
complicated than this is the twisted
tourists line so what you do in the case
of the twisted torus knot is you take
care of tpq torus knot you're taking
elbow strands then you put em twists on
you can view this as sort of the knots
genius to Jesus through surface so it
looks something like this and we call
this the TP qlm torso ok so now that
we've got these knobs we need to somehow
Jennifer grades and 3-manifolds right
can we do this by a process called on
gain surgery so what you do in a surgery
is is essentially basically let's say
you have a knot or some simplicity let
just say it's the unknot or which is
just the circle and another course over
here so if you take any nod you thinking
it a little bit and you'll get a
tortoise right or something close to a
tortoise with them twisting over then
what you do is you basically take the
compliment inside s3 right so you get
all this stuff around here right and so
now you have them you have on s3 but
it's missing a torus on the inside right
so now what you have to do is to make it
slightly more complex is you have to do
back in this chorus so how do you do
this right well if you want to glue back
in a torus right you have to specify
where the part essentially on the
meridians going to go right so basically
what you do is so by the specified
regulus meridians going to go I'll be
able to glue back in the entire chorus
so this is basically specified by a
rational number arm right because if I
don't know where R is equal to P over Q
that will correspond to basically if I
go
times around this way grabbing key times
around this so it's the same concept of
the Taurus right so I glued it back in
like this right and basically it'll take
you to this rational number R which
corresponds to the slope that you're
moving along and this is not and will
give you a three-month right so in a
recent paper by buff ie he showed that
if you pick a sufficiently large
rational no more are and course not put
some tourists on flip these forms he
will in fact get some of the L spaces
that we are looking for so the goal of
our research is to basically obstruct
the left or durability of the
fundamental groups corresponding to the
screen which which you know GL and two
are the rational okay so long before we
can do that we have to first give these
fundamental rich right so if you applied
second van Kampen to the process of gain
surgery you'll get that it's basically
just the fundamental group of the not
group which is if you have it or not you
take its complement inside s3 the
fundamental group you get from their
bought it out by on this relationship
you obtained from Dane surgery right so
indeed surgery you're gluing back in
this horizontal slope of rational over
arm right so say you have generators in
U and lambda basically corresponding to
the torus that's sitting inside your
original lung but sitting inside the
original freak like three half
back then if you go along mutti lambda
the P which corresponds it's moving
along this rational slope
it's exactly like they're moving along
this torus here which will just go to be
an identity so you just have to modify
this relationship where mu and lambda
are generators corresponds in the Torres
family you said that music if you wanted
people to wanna the ratios okay so mu
and lambda are called the generators of
this peripheral subgroup which is
isomorphic to secrecy because it's
essentially a torus yeah so here are
some pictures of the calculations we did
I'm not going to be going to exactly
what's going on here but basically this
corresponds to one of the generators of
tours from doing this kind of and talk
about the that's why I said manland are
the generators of the perils of the
torus boundary and so we derived the
knockers
oops note that see here is an expression
and me and the Seaford plus PK plus 1
cases
that's okay sir
right so where did it all start
we saw a paper by clan Watson and they
added a result where it's best think
Pete okay or M now they either had to
fix K or M so we have to try to
generalize that result for people's
three there was a lot of case working
Walt so what we did was we considered
cases where and we were positive or
negative but it turns out and gets stuck
with and we are both negative so we were
really stuck and then a paper by each
unit and one came out which basically
made of all our results useless because
they pretty much the group we were
analyzing was special case of their
general so we were like where do we go
from here
so there was another paper by the
fighting which divided all PK plus 1 l
space just a tourist not into three
classes le is 2 and l equals P minus 2 M
equals 1 and helices P minus 1 so
we wondered whether it was possible to
use the methods of EGR Ottumwa and adapt
them to the three cases of a fight and
that's exactly what we did so cleanly
Watson's general general case was just
the first case and we did this first
and our bound on art is larger than the
bound of day Michael Ian Watson
so it's better
so we proved it for l equals P minus 2 M
equals 1 and l equals P minus 1 but we
weren't able to prove it for Elephants 2
and that question still remains open but
the results we have so far supported the
L space-cadet you that's what we're
hearing
okay I'd like to talk about our
methodology how we got these results our
method of proof relies on a different
characterization of left over ability
than the one that Kat presented
definitionally in communities talk
basically we can view countable left
order groups as subgroups and homeo plus
R and it would become clearer as I
explained more terminology why this
characterization really helps us get our
results to explain why I need to
introduce the definition of global fixed
point which basically if you have a
group action this a real number it would
go back to all the real numbers a real
number is called a little fix point the
stabilizer of that number is the entire
group basically every element improve
fixative and the reason we care about
these global fix points is because of
the following proposition due to Boyer
whoops and reached which basically says
if you have a non-trivial group action
there must be another which isn't
actually with no global fixed points so
I'd like to walk through our argument
carefully if we assume by contradiction
that this portion group associated today
in surgery is left auricle then because
of the isomorphic to a subgroup of homeo
plus R which is the group of quarter
preserving homeomorphisms of the real
line under conversation I forgot to
mention that but if we assume that this
group is like horrible by contradiction
because that's the more victim subgroup
on Mir plus R there must be an objective
for a morphism for these groups to homeo
plus R which will obviously have
non-trivial image so therefore there
must be another such a little more
visible which has no global six points
therefore to prove our results in
submission show that every homework
these ammonia plus hopper has so the
natural question to ask is how can we
prove have your suddenly morphism
satisfies this condition as you can I
mentioned earlier eg our antenna did a
lot of work analyzing global fixed
points they basically said if you have
anak group in a specific form then every
homomorphism from the corresponding
quotient group after dancer which of
homeo are plus will have a global fixed
point and by the same argument that I
walked through earlier hence will not be
left forward
but unfortunately the condition that the
knot group is of this form seems to be a
little strict we were able to generalize
clay and Watson just applying their
theorem directly but to extend to the
results that we actually have which are
much larger classes of us-based mr.
tourist knots we needed to modify each
of our antennas conditions a little bit
so our main theorem is a modification of
each AR and tempest which rather than
require them to not group B of a
specific form just imposes these two
conditions that asks is a word that
contains all positive powers of
regenerators and that all homomorphisms
from the surgery groups to pull me about
plus satisfy this condition
these conditions actually turned out to
be a lot stronger we were not only able
to further generalize playing Watson but
through the second theorem that was
presented earlier which is an entirely
different class of else based twisted
tourists not specified by the bay
outlook but after he's got these results
what's still left so a little bit of
Uyghur as she can't have mentioned
before the serum my papi gives these
three different pieces twisted for us
knots which when you produce when you
perform some kind of surgery on them
given hell space we have these two
results for the first two cases we
haven't proven the fairy pay stitches
when you take these two strands and you
just go one full time to get the piston
to rest now and secondly we can talk
about so all the parents that we
presented and also those magnetic Walton
said for a sufficiently large surgery
sloop we get a fundamental group a
manifold you sentimental group is not
not verdict and it turns out if you have
but not which does permit a surgery that
gives a house based temple there's a
similar amount where for for all
surgeries greater than or equal to
certain number you will definitely get a
null space for anything less to think
will not get in a space and so it's
worth comparing whether or not if we
really want to verify this interaction
for all the cases we can we would like
this bounce to light now so that every
surgery which is a null space would also
have a fundamental group that's not
literal it turns out that the lower
bound that we get and also place of
Awesome's which is sort of just a
partisan sort of generality
they're not it turns out that the band
that we all get is slightly larger than
the minimum found on the surgery to
produce a mile spacing and so that means
that there are a lot of surgeries which
we actually know we've been all these
twisted tourist knots will produce else
pieces but you spend amount of groups we
don't necessarily know to be left for
durable so this is another case when I
think it's rotating this fountain and
verify the conjecture before it even
more animals and they've been renovated
so we have for you guys we like to thank
Jen Tom and Mike long they've been very
helpful they're teaching us discern the
next think though when we are a program
for giving us the opportunity to do all
this really interesting stuff and we'd
like to thank all of you for sitting
here listening to us
you can rephrase this in a more clear
theoretic sense if you just think of
like gain surgery since we're just
modding out this relation and religious
to a quotient group so you can rephrase
it a little more theoretically the
result if you yeah okay sure there
reason why we think about these knots is
that it's very convenient you saw with
this one computation we can forget all
the fundamental groups of all the
manifolds that these surgeries just by
by this one computation so that allows
us to Jenna to generate a lot of
different animals that we know the
fundamental group seven that are sort of
related at sausages pincushion groups so
that me is this mostly out of opinions
because this gives us a large classroom
ample to be easily but you certainly
could generalize at least the technique
probably also there results in spaces